sourit free bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec l'eau ce matin sur rtl
france alors viens de l'entendre un
rapport plutôt alarmant une
surpopulation en dépassant 200 % dans
certains établissements la présence de
rats comment en est on arrivé là
donc la surpopulation carcérale
notamment dans l'est dans la maison
d'arrêt puisque ce sont exclusivement ce
type d'établissement qui accueille des
prévenus et des condamnés courtes peines
qui sont concernés par ce phénomène de
surpopulation c'est quelque chose qui
existe depuis la nuit des temps ou moi
ça fait 22 ans que je suis dans cette
administration ça fait 22 ans que les
maisons d'arrêt sont surpeuplées alors
effectivement aux commandes en arrive là
bas ma foi on en arrive là parce qu'on
n'a peut-être pas assez de places de
prison pour incarcérer tout le monde
dans des conditions adéquates comment on
en est arrivé là sûrement parce que les
délais d'instruction est de passage en
procès sont peut-être parfois trop longs
et puis aussi parce que l'affectation
des détenus condamnés dans des
établissements pour peine où la danse
est nullement est individuelle et d'un
appoint parfois c'est très long aussi
parce qu'on n'a pas forcément les
structures adéquates en fonction des
profils et donc du coup ça prend un peu
plus de temps donc tout ça c'était
finalement un amalgame de plein de plein
de phénomènes qui ont aujourd'hui oui la
population pénale réaugmente puisqu'on
avait eu quand même un bon bol d'oxygène
au printemps 2020 avec les ordonnances
bébé dans le cadre de la crise sanitaire
mais on dénonçait déjà nous à l'époque
et les gongs qui est en train de se
produire aujourd'hui puisque dans la
mesure où la chaîne pénale a repris
de plein pot son activité m'a pas
derrière désincarcération réaugmente
voilà alors ensuite sur la présence de
rats il ya toujours eu des reins au pied
des établissements pénitentiaires tout
simplement parce que des gens qui jette
des détritus par les têtes et ce ne sont
pas les personnels pénitentiaires
alors justement vous avez évoqué
certains établissements qui sont
surpeuplés surtout les maisons d'arrêt
où sont enfermés justement des personnes
en attente de jugement des condamnés à
de courtes peines on parle d'un taux
voilà qui est vraiment très fort et ce
qu'il n'y aurait pas d'autres solutions
justement à ces condamnations en tout
cas à ces personnes qui sont en attente
justement d'être fixés sur leur sort et
qui se retrouvent justement dans des
prisons entassés les uns sur les autres
aujourd'hui on parle de deux là vous
parlez de 200% dans le reportage
aujourd'hui je vais vous donner un
exemple sur la région ile de france
on est en moyenne à 123 % sur l'ensemble
des prisons de la région parisienne
donc on est loin des 200 % alors
effectivement là de la situation est
quand même inquiétante surtout avec
l'arrivée de l'été
aujourd'hui il est évident également que
les conditions de détention sont les
conditions d'exercice des missions des
personnels et ses missions cette mission
est double puisqu'il est à la fois une
question de sécurité publique sécurité
des établissements mais aussi une
question de leur réinsertion et de
réhabilitation sociale
donc comment aujourd'hui pouvoir exercer
ses missions dans ces conditions là
c'est un peu difficile alors derrière la
solution oui effectivement il ya le
programme immobilier qui est engagée
depuis 2007 avec l'objectif de
construire quinze mille place nette pour
arriver à 75 mille places à l'horizon
mais d'ici là la vraie question c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait alors les
alternatives à l'incarcération
l'ufap unsa justice n'a jamais été fermé
là dessus bien au contraire
pour autant
ça doit s'accompagner ce genre de choses
avec des moyens matériels et surtout
humains
puisqu'aujourd'hui on va prendre
l'exemple notamment du bracelet anti
rapprochement qui a été développée et
mise en avant à grand renfort médiatique
par notre garde des sceaux mais le
nombre de personnels alloué à ce type de
mission reste le même alors dans les
postes de contrôle et notamment aussi
dans les services de probation et
d'insertion pour les dans lesquelles les
personnels sont amenés à se déplacer à
domicile pour mettre en place ce genre
de choses et dont on se retrouve avec
des effectifs légale à peau de chagrin
donc on veut bien faire des choses on
veut bien développer et moderniser notre
administration mais il faut derrière que
les moyens suivent et que notre ministre
ait de penser que le ch a créé cornes
bamakois qui importent les conditions et
de l'intendance suivra parce que nous là
aujourd'hui d'intendance ne s'occupe une
dernière question c'est que le rapport
épingle justement les conditions
matérielles de détention mais on parle
également de certaines allégations
d'insultés compris un caractère raciste
homophobe de la part de policiers
qu'est ce que vous attendez de la part
du gouvernement concernant justement
voilà c'est ces cas qui sont répertoriés
ce qui regarde la police ma foi je vais
laisser ça aux collègues de la police
puisque nous c'est ministère de la
justice donc monsieur darmanin va se
débrouiller avec ce genre de choses à
l'intérieur des établissements
pénitentiaires et poursuivre
de près les ordres du jour notamment des
conseils de discipline concernant les
personnels je vous prie croire que en
cas de manquement à la déontologie
pénitentiaire l'administration
pénitentiaire frappe fort ça c'était une
chose
seconde chose ce n'est pas non plus des
événements et des faits qui se déroulent
de manière régulière et récurrente alors
comme partout effectivement il peut y
avoir ma foi des brebis galeuses et des
dérapages mais dans ces cas-là
l'administration c'est en tout cas
l'administration pénitentiaire concert
responsabilités et je peux vous garantir
que l'ensemble des personnels à 99 9 %
exercent leur mission avec le plus grand
des professionnalisme merci beaucoup a
en tout cas où ils feraient de faim que
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
national et fap